what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 discussion video I wanted to do
something a little different for today's
video so I figured I would list 10 of
the biggest remaining theories that have
yet to come true there are hundreds or
even thousands of theories out there but
I only pick 10 for this video and these
are some of the theories that I would
love to see come true in the final
season I feel like most of these
theories will come true and if only half
of them happen I would be pretty
satisfied but leave a comment down below
and let me know which ones you want to
see come true the most if I leave any
off of this list that you like feel free
to leave it in the comments as well but
let's begin number one the valonqar this
one is a little controversial when
Cersei Lannister met Maggie the frog in
the show they left the valonqar part of
the prophecy out Cersei was told she
would not marry Prince Rhaegar but she
would marry the King instead and that
did happen Cersei was told that her
children would die and that happened as
well but they left one of the most
interesting parts out which foreshadows
Cersei zone death Maggy the Frog told
Cersei and when your tears have drowned
you the valonqar shall wrap his hands
about your pale white throat and choke
the life from you although this was left
out this hasn't stopped fans from
believing this would still happen to
Cersei Lannister there are also many
different theories about who the
valonqar could actually be some say it's
Tyrion while others say it's Jaime or
even Arya but personally I would love to
see Jaime Lannister be the one to do
this even though he no longer has two
hands I don't think that would be enough
to stop Jaime from choking her to death
in my opinion this would be the most
satisfying and this is something that I
need to see happen before the series
ends number 2 Jon Snow rides a dragon
this is another very popular theory that
has been around for over a decade and
this is another one that I would love to
see happen before the series is over now
that it is a hundred percent confirmed
John has Targaryen blood I think it's
also very possible this will happen
not only does Jon have the blood of the
Dragon but we have also already seen Jon
begin to form a bond with the Dragons
Daenerys only has two dragons left and
she can't ride both of them at the same
time someone needs to
Ragle into battle if Ragle did have a
rider it would be a lot harder for the
knight King to bring him down like he
did with us Ariane + Ragle was named
after John's father if anyone was going
to ride him it needs to be John
so HBO make this happen please number 3
cleganebowl fans have been waiting for
this showdown ever since season one but
hype has reached an all-time high ever
since the Hound and the mountain met
face to face in the dragon pit during
the season 7 finale the hound told his
brother he knew who was coming for him
he's always known and that person is the
Hound he has one on him dead ever since
he was a boy and I think that time will
finally come in season 8 I know the
mountain is still on Arya Starks list
and some people would like to see Arya
kill him but personally I want the Hound
to do it that would be the most
satisfying way to kill the mountain but
that's just my opinion
number four brain stark wargs Vasari on
this may be one of the least likely
theories to happen but it's still a very
cool theory nonetheless brain stark is
one of the most powerful characters in
the story and we have already seen him
warg into several different animals and
even Hodor but the ultimate showstopper
would be if bran stark and warg into a
dragon the full extent of brains powers
are not known but it's very obvious that
brain and the knight King have a strong
connection with each other the night
King was able to physically interact
with bran while he was in the weirwood
net but now that brain is starting to
harness his powers he may be able to tap
into the night Kings powers and possibly
take over his dragon bran has never
controlled anything that was dead but we
will see brain at his full strength in
the last season so there was no telling
what else he may be capable of bran will
never walk again but he will fly number
5 Jon and Daenerys will have a child now
this theory is somewhat new but there
was more than enough evidence to lead me
to believe it will happen
ever since season 1 Daenerys has assumed
she will never give birth to a child and
that may have been true back then but
that is no longer true now only death
pays for life and after Viserion died
that
may have been a form of payment that
would allow Daenerys to get pregnant
again now that she has slept with John
snows she may be pregnant come season 8
Jorah Mormont foreshadow John having
children in Tyrion foreshadow Daenerys
having children and even John foreshadow
Daenerys having children there were so
many hints over the course of season 7 I
would be surprised if this didn't happen
but we shall see number 6
King's Landing burns this theory has
been around for a while when it's also
been foreshadowed quite a few times we
have even seen glimpses of this in
season 2 when Daenerys had a vision that
the house of the undying and in season 4
when brain had multiple flashbacks as he
touched the weirwood tree beyond the
wall given the current state of Westeros
this is very likely to happen Cersei
Lannister has no plans of leaving King's
Landing and eventually this may lead to
an heiress no choice but to smoke Cersei
out by burning down the city Cersei may
even do this herself she has no problem
of burning things with wildfire but the
knight king is also south of the wall
and he's currently riding a dragon of
his own his final destination has yet to
be revealed but if he gets anywhere near
King's Landing then the capital was in
deep deep trouble some photos have
already came out that show they are
building a gigantic new set for season 8
and according to reports the new set is
going to be used for the streets of
King's Landing and they have already
done controlled fire tests on this set
if this is true we will most likely see
King's Landing burn when Daenerys is
finally able to step foot in the throne
room and may look exactly like she
envisioned while she was at the house of
the undying
personally I actually hope this does
happen not only would it look really
cool but that city deserves to burn it
stinks of corruption number 7 dance of
dragons 2.0 I think this one is pretty
much a guarantee at this point
a dragon burst dragon battle in the sky
this wouldn't be the first time this has
happened in Westeros but it would be the
first time it has happened what the dead
dragon I don't even think I need to go
into this one too much Daenerys has two
dragons and the night King has one at
some point next season they will meet in
the sky
and it should look pretty damn
spectacular let's just hope John is on
one of those dragons too if they are
going to spend money on CGI for a dragon
battle you might as well make it a
triple threat match only John and Danny
verse the knight King two dragons should
be able to take down one right they
better hope so number eight Theon the
hero now I know this might seem like a
long shot to some of you but fiona is a
new man who is on a mission he may have
abandoned his sister but after his
showdown on the beach Theon was baptised
in the sea what is dead may never die
but rises again harder and stronger I'm
just gonna come out and say this
Theon must kill his uncle you're on even
if he's not able to save his sister in
time Theon has been on a very long road
of redemption and it looked like his
story may have been close to an end when
he got his short-lived glory after he
saved songs oh but after urine captured
his sister and Theon fled it was very
obvious
Theon's character was not quite over he
is currently on his way to save his
sister and let's be honest here the odds
are not in Theon's favor but there is no
way they have kept this character alive
this long to not have his story end on a
very high note even if that means he
dies in the process in the end
Theon will not be remembered as the
coward he once was number 9 Zora hi this
theory has been around ever since the
first book came out and now that the
story is coming to an end on a
television show it's more relevant now
than ever before in season eight we will
finally find out if azor Ahai reborn
will be a literal and physical figure or
not for those of you that aren't as
familiar with this azor Ahai was a
legendary figure who forged a hero's
sword by plunging it into nice aneesa's
chests who was his wife and when he did
the sword combined with her soul and it
caught fire making the sword
Lightbringer the sword of all swords
that would lead to fight to win the
darkness that laid over the world and it
danced with Dragons
Jon Snow has a dream that he is standing
on top of the wall as others are
climbing
the law but in John's hand he is holding
a burning red sword so you have to
wonder if John will be the one to end up
with the burning sword or was it just a
dream Ana's aura hide just another story
passed down from generation to
generation we know Melisandre firmly
believes in this prophecy and we have
also seen burning swords before in this
show but will we ever see light bringer
personally I would love to see this
happen but only time will tell
number 10 john defeats the night king
this may be the theory that i want to
see the most i would love to see john
crushed the night king on the
battlefield or even in the sky while
they ride dragons i would be satisfied
either way john in the night king i've
had two very tense staredown so far and
at some point there needs to be some
kind of payoff it's not going to be easy
and he will certainly need help
but if john is truly the one to lead the
fight against the dead then he needs to
be the one to kill the night king and in
this war against the others for good
Daenerys and John are on their way to
Winterfell when the night King and his
army are heading south so it's just a
matter of time before they meet again
but the question remains who will win I
want to thank everyone for watching my
top 10 list of the theories that I want
to see happen to most don't forget to
leave a comment letting me know which
theories you want to see come true are
there any good ones I should have put on
my list let me know before I go I have
to thank everyone on patreon who
continues to support this channel I hope
everyone has a great day and Happy
Holidays
I will see you all in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
you